can you talk about the what were you
supposed to do in Star Wars and what
happened that's got to be a very tough
franchise in solo in song yes well the
character's name was on his it was a
Dryden box and he was a he was half a
mountain lion half human
he was extremely sophisticated very rich
like a he had been around the world old
a guy and he was on and I think it was
sort of a love triangle between Amelia
Amelia Clark's character Keira and the
young Han Solo not that way it was
overtly a love triangle but there was
definitely some some some some a pissing
contest going on for the girls of
shooting right and he's old and in one
is younger so it was that thing also
going on like young buck I've been I've
been around the world he's like yeah but
the young buck you know the young the
young chick once the young buck yeah so
it was a little bit of that energy going
on but but the relationship was on the
paper was definitely with Keira and Han
Solo but it was definitely there's some
energy going up to Mike because in the
air who's in the air right so um we shot
that man and um and then I wrapped and
then I went on to Africa to shoot a red
sea diving resort you know what Kevin
Chris Evans and and the whole gang out
there and then I get the phone call that
80% into the movie is only 20% left the
shooter in the movie Lucas Films and and
the directors the brothers for who
directed the the the infamous are Legos
movies they didn't see eye to eye
anymore
and were they were fired so arm they
bought in um Ron Howard and they said
look we want to see can you steer the
ship back in this direction right and um
how long would it take me to do that he
says give me a few days to assess the
damages and I get back
- when he got back you know in regards
to you know Michael K Williams character
you know if you want me to save that you
we're gonna have to reshoot it in its
entirety
oh wow was it they wanted to change
certain elements of how you are yeah I'm
guessing you know it was different it
was you know yeah it was definitely a
difference in direction in in direction
you know the the brothers from Legos
film they I think they were taken the
franchise in a different direction and
what it was not working for Lucas Films
so when there was a better than the
David creative differences
so at the end of the day um they were
asked to leave and Ron ha was born in to
stare it back a little in the opposite
direction more along the lines for Lucas
Films and that's where the issue came in
of my character being needing needing to
be reshot I was just already on another
job you're doing something else here and
so they said well well we want to keep
the release date the same and and
reshoot it how what would that would
take we need to get him right back right
now and that wasn't gonna have begged
the company or the production you were
doing like a look of Star Wars franchise
let me or did you just realize you cut
this I you know there are certain things
that I've been in Hollywood enough to
know if the you know just you know
anything could happen right now seen a
lot of crazy [ __ ] you know that was one
for the textbooks that that was just so
out of left field there's just some
things you know you know Jimmy's gotta
say you know what it's out of my hands
it's out of my hands that is like a
freak accident what are the odds that
that [ __ ] happened right so just you
know I just saw I accepted a I accepted
that I was exactly where I was supposed
to be I was in Africa and I wasn't gonna
I just wasn't gonna do that
it just didn't make sense and what it
wouldn't have made us a difference a
team again yeah did we were already that
day I was contracted I was there right
that wasn't gonna happen and I just you
know just let it go
yeah I guess you have to it's
frustrating to have to pass up work but
if you're passing it up for other work
yeah so we call that rich people
problems